hello and welcome to this video playing
a carbon dowels and see what he does
Ritchie opening
so we're this is a typical halfway to
play prevent them prevent five what is
Queenie five doing and you know really I
mean what is the Queen doing on its own
okay
I'm hook you one can almost play h3 and
I mean if he takes is going to have the
sir
we should trapped would okay there's no
needs to be a excessively fancy here
it's a little bit better for white
anyway this position because he has
weakened it to inside could be five and
so on again it's nothing decisive but I
am strongly prefer white him my thinks
and to be five looks normal
I have to watch out the energy form he's
got some stuff going for him here on f2
this also threatens bishop deform which
is not there is no reaction to it I
don't know how bad it is and cannibal
crenate six but this is also a good wolf
and my original intention
now that looks good and so take now
night to be six is that winning
something almost Chinese got look the
eight so I can play night here Fisher
defaults also on what's happening there
this is actually an interesting question
where is he going
lots of screw heads are not that great
yeah
Quincy 796 it's not good when d7 runs
into a fork c5
yes c5 Bishop f6 isn't dead winning a
piece thought that wins stuff d5 is
hanging now Bishop g2 Bishop g7 I'm a
piece up yeah so he plays with the piece
down now hoping to mate andriy to you
maybe I should have gone to a one for
Queen c3 right okay this is this is not
a bad way to do it
so take a three doesn't really feel very
important but I can I can aim for h6
myself so Queen age six alright I can
also do this Queen I'm gonna crank onion
this is good ham the rook is also a
checked so there is no Queen eat or
something fancy I can take it even okay
and then that should be really the end
of it not this one
after six I can just take
black resigns yakin he essentially
blunder the peano the position was
already a little bit questionable yeah
um this is a line we always think of
it's a little bit more comfortable for
white but again nothing special I don't
don't really think that this helps all
that much but erm okay I want misty for
that's a big miss actually could have
done that
and here it's um yeah this is okay this
is okay for black I never this but he
also has ninety five and eighty three
and so on there was a default big move
here that that he missed deform and that
means that my move here is not good this
is this is just nice for white was
amazed about the engine I mean why isn't
white better his Queen side is weak I
mean okay maybe this is just this kind
of thing that is easier to play for
widened I mean here I was completely
certain that that then it's huge and
here the engine actually agrees h5 is
kind of the non move it it doesn't do
anything Queen a form came
and back it's not very intuitive again I
would always prefer widen the term this
is a nice position and this ultimately
worked very well I mean he doesn't he
has many many squares that are not great
yeah like this is 96 sorry threatening
here and the rook why and this is very
obvious you know and then ready did also
doesn't forget it loses a piece for
absolutely nothing
yeah ok guys thanks for watching